putin might have just won the war in  ukraine russia supplies europe with 40  percent of its energy via its natural  gas pipeline north stream one and putin  just shut off that pipeline right before  the start of a very cold european winter  so winter is coming while europe's  energy supply just dropped by almost  half that means if europe doesn't come  to the negotiation table with putin fast  there's going to be protests riots civil  unrest economic collapse maybe even  revolutions it would be too expensive  for people to power or heat their homes  businesses will shut down countries that  will skyrocket and putin is going to use  this pressure to get exactly what he  wants subscribe to find out what happens  next